a new poll shows that Joe Biden has
surged ahead in the race for the
Democratic nomination in 2020 the poll
shows that 46% of Democrats are backing
Joe Biden as the potential nominee with
only 14% backing Bernie Sanders and
despite a lot of other polls telling a
very different story the media has
jumped on this one voices are now
telling us why he's the best choice for
the Democrats and this is a guy who
doesn't hate Republicans like you see
some of the folks on the Left forgive
minute for Joe Biden is that he's the
most electable candidate for Democrats
to beat Donald Trump I think Joe Biden
is our best chance of success there's a
sudden coronation remind you of anything
Hillary Clinton is the best candidate
Democrats can put forward to take on
Donald Trump voters in Wisconsin think
Hillary Clinton is the best candidate
the media tells us that Joe Biden is the
most experienced candidate Biden is
certainly the most experienced candidate
I think Hillary Clinton is the single
most experienced and prepared person who
has ever run for president of the United
States furthermore it stresses the point
that Biden is a centrist he's actually
kind of a centrist a centrist which is
one of the reasons why I think
Republicans fear him more than the
others Hillary Clinton is not threatened
in terms of the nomination because she
is a pre moderate centrist Democrat and
in fact Biden's first campaign
fundraiser happened at the home of the
exact same guy his name is David Cohen
he's the chief lobbyist for the media
conglomerate known as Comcast now both
Biden and Clinton voted for the Iraq war
both Biden and Clinton have lots of Wall
Street donors and both Biden and Clinton
screamed to lock him up in the 1990s
driving America's incarceration rates
sky-high for those who may have
forgotten Hillary Clinton lost Trump's
victory in the 2016 election was
interpreted largely as a rebuke of a
failing political establishment now
Hillary Clinton's husband got some
interesting advice years ago my wife
gave me a psychology book several months
ago in which the author defined insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and over again and expecting a different
result
perhaps it's
time to revisit that book polls are
often a reflection of media coverage and
the corporate media in the United States
loves him and gives him lots of coverage
and that can give him support in polls
and they often pull likely Democratic
voters which is not the same thing as
who actually ends up voting in a general
election even just who answers polls is
not the same thing as who votes Clinton
she was the most experienced and the
most right-wing of the Democrats and the
media loved her but it didn't mean she
could get elected in fact the polls were
overwhelmingly clear time and time again
media appreciate them their massive
purchases of advertising as Joe Biden
2020 has already engaged in but the
media liking someone and telling
everyone they're the leading candidate
as they did overwhelmingly with Hillary
Clinton does not in any way obvious mean
that that is a candidate who's going to
win an election
you